good afternoon
ladies and gentlemen
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen dear
colleagues welcome welcome to all of you
welcome to this inter parliamentary
committee meeting composed of members of
the Foreign Affairs Committee here in
the European Parliament members of the
EU national parliaments including many
many chairs of the relevant committees I
would like to welcome you from all the
member states of the European Union
additionally I would like to welcome a
number of observers from a Norwegian
Parliament as well as from the
parliaments of Montenegro and
bosnia-herzegovina a warm welcome I
would also like to welcome since this is
a meeting which is not in camera a group
of journalists I was able to speak to
this noon journalist from the six
Western Balkan countries who are in
Brussels for a few days I hope you're
sitting somewhere here in the committee
meeting welcome to all of you too and
you'll be just as interested as we are
in following I guest speakers first of
all let me welcome among us and it's a
real honor and pleasure for me to
welcome him he's Venu Lee appointed High
Representative and vice-president of the
European Commission and this is his
first public appearance in the European
Parliament
a warm welcome yours FRL thank you for
coming
[Applause]
since mr. Birrell is under time pressure
and he has to fly to Bratislava
later in the day I would without further
ado like to first of all give him the
floor to present his working plan as a
high representative and vice president
and then we have time for a debate and
you'll indicate me when you have to
leave mr. Birrell the floors yours but
after Luna thank you very much to all of
you a working plan is maybe too much but
let's share with you what's happening
and what can we do first
let me tell you that I am very happy to
be here again it is literally my third
day of my term as High Representative VB
I've been in at Paris likova Samba
leader to hound remise to the French
soldiers who were killed in sire Molly
last day and I was also at the opening
of the Climate Change Conference in
Madrid - very symbolic events of the
world we are living and also very
symbolic of the work we have to do today
at the College Commission first meeting
we have been dealing about climate
change and the international and
external dimension of this very
important challenge for Europe I said
during my heating here that I would like
to work in close collaboration with
European Parliament and with the
national parliaments because I have very
much convinced of the human fundamental
role that you will play on defining a
credible European foreign policy but to
be credible it has to be United and
today we have a lot of
differences among member states that we
cannot hide have to face them and to try
to build a common policy overcoming
these differences I will concentrate my
introductory remarks on two parts first
the Europe's plays in a more competitive
world and the second they need and the
meaning of this geopolitical approach is
geopolitical commission that president
under levin underlined has already
mentioned several times i think it's
quite clear the return of a strategic
competition between major powers why
globalization and economic
interdependence we thought it was going
to reduce it by the contrary military
competition is coming back much more
than we thought and our military effort
must therefore increase both
qualitatively and quantitatively and
today is a good day to talk about it
since as you know it is taking place the
Assembly of the NATO in London in the
middle of quite a lot of let's say
disagreements strong statements about
the future of this organization we have
to understand and spite our immense
wealth and creativity Europe will see if
only for demographic reasons its
economic weight weaken in the world in
the coming decades
so our unity is the condition for our
survival and defence is one of the key
instruments of the survival we are
living a strong comeback
of power politics and this coincides
with the explosion of threats emanating
from non-state actors on the periphery
of Europe in this hell is a good example
romantic example on those days and in
the Middle East the threats are adding
up so we will have to require to have an
array of instruments which are wider
more flexible and quickly operational
the classic instruments of the soft
power we where defining ourselves our
soft power Commerce science technology
are becoming today powerful tool of a
global competition between state soft
harp our are becoming deeply intertwined
see yes we are living in a more
competitive world and the only way to
face it is to react collectively with
the European Union foreign policy oh by
the contrary to resign ourselves to be
the playground of the others all of you
in your parliamentarian work see this
every day our politic is back unite this
stage is pursuing a more nationalist
approach au natural approach we face
increasing threats coming from the east
and China we have been defining this big
country as much as an economic partner
as a rival you know about instability in
the neighborhood and the challenges and
Africa represents on the next bring a
First Consul next Monday we are going to
deal with Africa specially to prepare
the big meeting the big cement with
African countries and president all sort
of underlying is going to visit
Africa Sun terrorism climate change
hybrid threats disinformation campaigns
all these new threats are not the kind
of threat that we were trying to respond
by implementing article 5 of NATO NATO
remains the basic tool of the
territorial defence of many European
countries but at the same time we have
to realize that there are other new
threats that require a specific answer
and this specific answer has to mobilize
our energies we must anticipate problems
before they become acute we need a more
common strategic culture in order to
make us agree more and surely we must
get better at acting faster when we have
to do and finally since I am talking to
the European Parliament also I would
like to remember that we need an
ambitious external action budget that
gives us the means to enhance our global
presence and to respond and rapidly to
crisis situation President Musharraf on
the line said the other day in Paris
that she expects to have a 30% increase
on the funding for external policies I
am sure I will have your strong support
even a 30% increase would maybe be too
much second not not too much okay but
difficult to get it
second the need for a geopolitical
approach and what does it mean everybody
has been repeating the sentence of
president von der Leyen this is a
geopolitical commission we also have
hurt presidents macron wake-up call
interview controversial
as they twitch from President Trump not
so much but his commands on NATO
attracted a lot of attention and the
debate has to continue the leaders
meeting in London has just convey a
message of unity although it's clear
that important issues among allies they
still require further discussion I think
we have to face this discussion frankly
among us NATO has salsa mythical
international political projects has
undergone different crises through its
existence this one is not the first one
and has managed to overcome them
successfully since the slowest time till
Iraq war in fact in our experience
crisis often lead to strengthening and
the present situation highlights the
need for the European Union
to continue advancing on its own
development and an international
security actor and start thinking of
itself strategically as a geopolitical
power otherwise our future there is
being decided by others for me you have
to be aware of what is going on around
us and getting serious about building an
integrated foreign policy this is my
work someone wrote on the Treaty of the
Union that I am in charge of ensuring
coherence of the external policies of
the Union you can understand it's a big
challenge to ensure coherence of the
external policy of the European Union
member states and European institutions
but we have to do it we have to align
the work of the external Action Service
the Commission the Member States with
the strong backing of the Parliament
I repeat we live in a geopolitical world
where big play players US Russia China
but also Turkey among others act in a
geopolitical way they openly link issues
and instruments and use all levers of
power hard and soft today for example
United State has said that they are not
backing our much-needed tax on the big
Giants of the digital economy and
threatening with retaliation to the
countries who adopt these measures Libya
maybe has a good example they would like
to talk about it just across the
Mediterranean instability in Libya
threatens directly our security and
challenges our values with respect to
migration and asylum seekers it's in our
immediate neighborhood if it is
important that the European Union take
the lead working with regional actors in
support of United Nations to look for
the political situation for this failed
country we have been saying this for
many years that it has not happened the
situation continues to worsen and takes
many turns with an increasing number of
external players intervening we must
avoid that bilateral actions further
fuel conflict with Libya and increase
instability in the broader region the
recent agreement between Turkey and
Libya about the waters in the
Mediterranean which we still don't know
the content but has created a lot of
concern among in Greece I've been
talking with the Foreign Affairs
Minister in Greece before he was flying
to London
he's another example
we are a major diplomatic power we are a
financial superpower our trade policy in
spite of all criticism is a success
story we have built and will keep on
creating a network of trade agreements
and a condition of being sustainable
from the point of view of development
objectives in any one of our
negotiations we have to include more and
more discontinuation we are also adding
in the field of security and defence
notably with pesco and the European
defence fund that you will have to deal
with on the next financial perspective
I will chairing the external relation
cluster today the present of the
Commission had presented to the college
the rules of engagement if I can say the
rules of procedure how are we going to
work and I will have the responsibility
of presenting every week a state of the
international problems and chairing a
cluster of Commissioners the most
directly related with external policies
although climate change the migration
and not among them and they are part of
the most important international
challenges we have to face let's put a
good first example let's talk about for
example who said the rules who said the
rules will rule the world we are in a
battle of ideas of a rules and now about
the story that we tell to our citizens
and how do we rethink what does it mean
from the point of view over than the
standing of the world text example of
data and privacy data is the lifeblood
of the new economy according to someone
the total value the total value or the
data driven economy is bigger and the
value of the global oil trade so the
rules on data matters as much as the
rules of energy in the u.s. the rules
essentially imply that data belong to
the firms of the IT sector or digital
platforms in China data belong to the
state in Europe data belong to the
individuals which model will win in the
end
the firm's state or the individuals
which means society when in Europe we
are rightly proud of our model of
organizing our societies and economies I
don't want to be transfer list but we
have a unique mix of democracy
individuals freedom enshrined in law
economic prosperity and social
solidarity in the 90s we thought there
would be a global process of convergence
around these concepts but we know it it
hasn't been the case instead there is a
competition among political systems
when you say China is a systemic rival
what do we mean by that but do we mean
the word system systemic rival means
trivializing on systems and it's not
obvious that a group of countries
that represents today less than 9% of
the world population will prevail unless
and him coming back at the beginning of
my intervention unless we act together
we have been fisting the fall of burning
wall I was in Berlin and then many
believed that there were no alternative
to the system of liberal democracy a
market economy
remember this is the end of the history
some claim but history has no end the
Soviet system was not a better
alternative for people's well-being as
many of you know very well but in China
hundreds of millions of people have come
out both poverty performing one of the
most spectacular transformation in the
history of mankind and in not so a
distant future Africa will have over 1
billion people more more I was having
dinner yesterday with Jeff research and
we were talking about the demographic
explosion of Africa how can we manage it
and the figures that are coming without
anyone being able to manage them to not
look at Africa only through the eyes of
migration but we cannot hide the fact
that the demographic disequilibrium and
the gwelf this equilibrium between the
two shores of the Mediterranean will
increase a lot only acting together we
can be a partner to Africa and only
acting together we can have balanced
relations with China our approach should
be based on the respect of human rights
and sustainable development world but it
is not clear
that our partners will have the same
objective so we have to insist on what
does it mean this European Green New
Deal which has been debated to dehl in
the Commission as yesterday and during
those days in Madrid on the conference
on climate overall the nature of foreign
policy is changing foreign policy is not
what it was to use but what it used to
be foreign policy is not a matter of not
only diplomatic talks it covers every
aspect of the industrial technological
and geopolitical revolution who is
approaching and I think that we have to
start thinking big if we want to face
this challenge let me say something
about some geographical approaches first
Western Balkans
they have been also in the news and
there is a big disappointment in the
Balkans about the impossibility or the
refusal of going on on the enlargement
process we cannot deny the European
perspective of the Balkans as I said in
my hearing I would like to go to Serbia
Kosovo zones but in Kosovo there is
still no government and there is not
it's not useful to go before a
government was forward so we will not be
able to fulfill my promise of my first
visit going to Kosovo and I will go to
gratis lava which is nearby
because in Bratislava is today the OSCE
our same meeting and they will met
Foreign Affairs ministers of Russia and
all countries in the east we have to
continue supporting Ukraine as well as
Georgia
Luva as I said we have to have a leading
role in helping rebuild the Libyan state
in partnership unity nation and others
we have to have a comprehensive approach
to the multiple conflicts in the Gulf
next week we are going to chair the
meeting about the nuclear deal in order
to ensure that this deal is not being
completely broken and it is with this
spirit that we will be meeting the Joint
Commission tomorrow and Friday and
finally a word on the Sahel just as an
homage to the French soldiers kill there
that the trend remains negative it was
just in Paris to spread my solidarity
with France for the losses the army has
suffered and I want to tell you that we
must continue a collective efforts in
Sahel we cannot let some film European
countries bearing the burden or ensuring
this big big part of Africa whether
demographic bomb is increasing in
population and where the states are not
able to provide the public services that
are the basis of any kind of political
organization we Europeans have to be
very much engaged with this part of the
world because a lot of our threats are
being incubated there I don't want to go
further I hope and I expect to have a
good exchange of views with you about
this another issues today we have
launched a communique may be the first
one of my mandate talking about this
agreement within
turkey Olivia which was very worrisome
for Greece and I hope also to be able to
have more information on that at the
meeting advantage lava this evening and
tomorrow I am at your disposal to hold a
frank and open debate because they think
we have to say things clearly each other
there a lot of differences among
European countries a lot of differences
the only way of overcoming these
differences is explaining them in order
to understand which are the deep reasons
that one country and another have with
respect and given problem and I know
that these different approaches are
based on our history which has deep
roots in centuries behind us but if we
want to forge a common future we have to
overpass these differences to build a
common history of survival of the
European civilization thank you thank
you
[Applause]
Thank You vice president High
Representative per L colleagues we now
have the following situation mr. Birrell
has about fifty minutes time and I have
more than twenty-five requests to speak
and giving the floor I have to respect
geography political groups gender
equality and many more so it's an
absolute mission impossible but one
thing is clear that I will first always
give the floor to our guests from the
member states and then I will give the
floor to an MEP and you said why don't
we do the following thing if you've got
received enough questions you say stop
and then you do a first round or do you
want to do one on one what's better for
you maybe take several months and you
indicate stop because when you take the
blame when you say stop and then I'll be
happy so the first speaker and by the
way the colleagues from the member
states speaking cards have been handed
out if you would like to request a floor
so without further ado I would first yes
and because so many qualities want to
speak try and keep it to one one and a
half minutes I have a hammer here and
not to hock on your net but on this
wooden plate here we start with middle
Kovich from Croatia thank you so much
chairman I'm happy that don't have to
change my sex so I can still remain a
male and ask a question thank you so
much chairman congratulations once again
to the vice president to the to the high
representative I very much appreciated
his his presentation and I very much
agree with mr. Burrell that the European
Union is a power a financial power an
economic power and we should also become
in the Neff huge a political power and
you if you want to become political
power and play a role on the global
scene if you want to be global player we
have to show to ourselves and to the
world that we are the Masters
on the European continent we take care
of security and stability on the
European continent prefer an Chile
preferably it is us and that means that
we should also take care of the Western
Balkans and I very much hope that with
your support with your engagement we
will have next here a decision about the
opening of the negotiations with our
friends in North America and Albania
thank you so much thank you middle
coverage from the European Parliament
for the EPP group miss off go right
Encantada senior minister okay
bein Encantada develop in an elemental
and I'm going to continue in English for
my colleagues as my colleague from a
national parliament has said best in
Balkan is a focus of the of the European
Parliament we had the Western Balkan
strategy we had we have a peace and
security issue it is a I feel really sad
that you are not going to be able to
travel to mate pay your first visit and
Western Balkan to show symbolically how
peace and security issues are important
for you because peace and security is a
one common denominator that we can
create our joint foreign policy in the
future and peace of security is being at
stake now and we are having taken
hostage by Turkey as well for these
millions of refugees that being menaced
to be let if we don't make deals so my
my question and my really my request is
to follow the recommendation by European
Parliament in our resolutions on all
these countries and to take as your
personal mission to reassure the peace
and security will be played at the
frontier with European Union at
Southeast board south southeast border
otherwise we won't be able to play any
role
in the world thank you thank you from
the national parliaments mr. Gutierrez
lemonis from Spain thank you
I would like to talking in Spanish you
don't mind primer lugar Felicia Terra
yellow real delegate paniolo Thomas
orgulloso de su nombre supramonte a
nombre en tow tres preguntas breve
primero el a principal cielo meant a
Roper al venti Cinco for central ah
publishing mundial ACA por ciento era
entonces nos vamos seventy syncope o
centro LPM pronto sir Moselle Dec say
por ciento la toma decisiones pro enema
Dada exampie allahu la mayoría paulo
faqad aparecer kappa de ser competitive
o con otra grande potency a--'s del
mundo que la adición prácticamente por
una forma we lateral como Spence a Moses
arezzo I Yuna Creasy into personal
political Konami gay social app in
America el papel que debe jugar euro
palomino rupiah Repetto está en Espana
como puente de chocolate in America
yo Ultimo la política migratory Akane
gran acuerdo
I in complement of a part a uno PI sin
Cola quotas can occur upon D 1 SN
equilibrio Buteyko more upon solid
tambien de de la política de seguridad
ain't a la política me editorial control
a Frontera equal a solos all onto the
soccer ball a solo socket Evo's
princi-pal a que tenemos a kennel Ostrom
gonna topple ET coming a Toria then fo
me Feliciano much easy matter to thank
you for the S&D group in the European
Parliament mr. Pitts Allah Thank You mr.
chairman
day mr. Birrell mr. high representative
I'm glad to see you today in the
European Parliament and beside
congratulations I wish you nothing but
the very best in all your future
endeavors as High Representative and
vice president let remind you in your
declaration of intent you identify
realism unity and partnership as guiding
principles in helping to build a
stronger common foreign and security
policy for Europe this mean that you
you should learn to think and act as a
heart or even better smart power in an
integrated manner between the members
step and you you instruments this would
however represent a big change in the
way the Union acts so far till recently
hard security was guaranteed by the
United States from NATO however now some
key you member States publicly
demonstrate their disagreements on the
role and the future of NATO building a
more autonomous defense capacity in
response to the u.s. retreat from the
multilateralism might potentially
distance European Union from the NATO
and the US my question is as the High
Representative how do you see your role
in ensuring that this discussion between
member states is constructed and focused
on tangible capabilities such as defense
architecture operational readiness and
adequate budgeting thank you thank you
to Nino one more okay then we have from
the national parliaments madam
Gregor Church from Slovenia Thank You
mr. chair
in Slovenia we share the view that the
EU should be an important reliable and
responsible global player and it can
even gain more influence with more
coherent and coordinated actions on the
world stage if taking into account the
quick changes on the global level we see
the EU as a strong supporter of
multilateral cooperation the you must
also do further reports for a joint
security and defense cooperation
especially in the area of hybrid and
cyber threats the external actions of
the EU and of all the Member States in
their relations with the third countries
should be uniform coordinated and
proactive our common orientation must be
strengthening peace democracy security
rule of law and the respect of human
rights and fundamental freedoms
in Slovenia we will certainly continue
to be an active player in ensuring peace
security and political stability in the
you neighborhood with particular
attention to the Western Balkans the
history teaches us that this is a very
sensitive region with still many
unsolved problems the European
perspective is more or less the common
goal of all the Western Balkan states
but as a leading actor you must be also
credible and reliable thank you thank
you
first round mr. Poirot thank you a chair
well many questions were related to the
Western Balkans I strongly believe that
that it cannot be questioning the new
policy towards Western Balkans it has to
remain on the top of the European agenda
the issue of enlargement has created
some questions recently the least we can
say but on the long term or medium-term
perspective I think nothing has changed
and we have to work hard in order to
prepare the may 2020 we stirred Balkan
summit call for the Croatian president
in Zagreb this way this will be a
critical point to give an answer to all
your questions in the meantime we have
to maintain the momentum and to continue
working with all Member States in order
to make everybody understand that we
cannot close we cannot cancel the
European perspective of these countries
we were not able we are not able to
avoid the Yugoslavian war who made
almost 100 150 thousand casualties
was a big tragedy and the inheritance of
this tragedy has created divisions has
created poverty has created ethnic and
nationalist fight Europe is the only one
who can offer a solution to this
situation and I think in the council
this issue we have to be debated again
until the Zagreb meeting from my part I
can ensure the strong engagement of the
Commission with this region I think with
that I am answering at least two or
three of the questions another one is
about NATO what's happening with the
with NATO today I think that we have
three fall problems with respect to NATO
and the relationship of the European
Union with NATO first the perception
that the u.s. is more interested in Asia
than in Europe is not a perception is a
reality the fact of life the
indo-pacific is the real front line of
our time it's not in the middle of
Europe Asia is much more important
second a certain lack of consistency in
the u.s. stance on Syria and the Gulf we
have been criticizing this lack of
consistency there's another fact of life
we cannot agree with his attitude and
third the u.s. engagement linked to its
economic interest these three facts
condition very much the perception of
the alliance from the European point of
view
but NATO I said during my hearing and I
continue saying is the basic defense
framework for most European countries
and the only thing we can do is to
strengthen the NATO overcoming these
differences and at the same time develop
complementaries capacities built by
Europeans ourselves in order to face our
immediate problems doesn't let me tell
one figure when the British will leave
the European Union if they do 80 percent
of the military spending of the NATO
will be provided by non European Union
countries so we will be providing just
20 percent of the military capacity of
the NATO we are part of it but we are
not the most important part of it and we
have problems in our immediate
neighborhood that cannot be solved by
calling implementation of article 5 and
these three things perception that the
US has moved to Asia lack of consistency
on Syria and the Gulf an engagement
linked to economic interest very much
having a role on the perception that we
European half of the Alliance add up to
this the turkey strategic orientations
see the action of Turkey and Syria and
will understand our concerns but don't
believe that this is the first crisis of
the route of the NATO we had very much
divergent position in the past since the
1956 Suez operation by French and
British the Kippur War Libya in 86 Iraq
in 2003 our more recently Syria it's not
the first time
we disagree the important thing is to
maintain what it keeps us together the
fact that for the European NATO is the
basic framework our collective defense
and other question was about immigration
border control look you cannot believe
that we are going to solve the migration
problems by border control only the
borders have to be sure if a state
cannot ensure their borders is no longer
state so both a control is something
that we need to implement in order to
ensure our citizens but it is not the
only way of dealing with migration we
will not stop the waves of migration
that we don't act on the source of the
problem where the problem is being
produced not where the problem is being
manifested and it requires agreements
for partnership on development of the
African countries and agreements in
order to be able to send back people who
are irregular migrants and at the same
time ensure a coelom to the people who
really deserve it
migration policy is a important part of
the foreign policy and this Friday two
of my colleagues in the Commission will
travel to Ankara to discuss with the
Turkish authorities what to do with the
increasing number of migrants arriving
to the Greek islands which are no longer
Syrians escaping from the war for mainly
people coming from Afghanistan that may
be they are anticipating the
consequences of the peace agreement with
the Taliban and the last question is
about Latin America
do you allow me to answer to to to
answer the question about Latin American
Spanish it wouldn't be very strange for
me to talk about Latin America in
English or in French especially if I am
addressing to a Spanish colleague well
there's the law hibiscus to be a key
America latina Stein's and the other the
ultima vez que esto en este parlamento
cuando America latina solo era Venezuela
Cuba recuerden our oysters de Chile
hasta mexico que uno tras otro mucho
spices Samba stumble toes en gravis
desorden SOC allas ESO no es in or a
consequence e Adela's creciente x'
Desigual dades kayra democracia no Acedo
capaz de Betar durante los steed años de
Stabila de política either crecimiento
economical yah general Dunamis re Activa
en la que una Chispa producin s Procyon
Elysee mesclun conflict owes and Nikko's
con conflict o sociales con conflict
owes politico's to disown espanol pero
no lo dijo porque se espanol Europa
tiene que priests are Mucha mess
attention America latina pork astora
parece que Lugo problema que Viera Cuba
Yakub patria mente no es el mejor
problema es un problema pero la
situation in Chile M Bolivia en Ecuador
Venezuela
por supuesto in Colombia con los de her
sito's volviendo de nuevo a las calles
una imagen terrible a en el in
consciente colectivos latinoamericano
calm we're toes poor bala
en las calles de las ciudades es algo a
lo que la lunar Opia
no puede permanecer en absoluto in
differente
creo que todo lo que my impression tada
ustedes no se si tenemos algunas minutos
mass in our Presidente second round mr.
Birrell is that okay for you yeah okay
then next is from the European
Parliament miss von kramm on well that's
a pleasure thank you
since you have already mentioned that
the cost of a question can only be your
question I mean the trip to Kosovo to
the Balkans can only be solved after the
government is formated
I think I'm gonna keep to two other
questions one would be looking at
Ukraine that is also at a crucial
juncture the Normandy format we'll meet
at the upcoming Monday in in Paris and I
know we are not part of the Normandy
format but nevertheless we have a big
interest that Ukraine won't fail and
also we have I think or we should have a
strategic outreach to Ukraine what would
be your let's say proposal for the
Ukrainians for the Russian side but also
for the German and for the French how
could they end up and what would be a
sustainable solution maybe in a nutshell
and the second question of course for me
is always I mean the Russian influence
in one not only one of our neighbours
countries but also in our member states
here and probably also in your region of
Catalonia Italy the brexit was was
meddled by by the Russians what would be
adequate measures from the European
Union to have to be Morris Island to
what's Russian influence thank you thank
you from the national parlance next on
my list is Miss Julie glue from France
presidential / peasant on a locked res
militancy dopiest embarked on on tt3
O'Malley resume and Anya she would
really nice acocella security the low
hop
chair Callahan's DiFonzo la mouche aloha
presentation via KO vote presence on dat
extra more oppressive no security
tambien coma the stability de Salcedo
Cecil do Maghreb a donk de la ayuda de
la méditerranée certain priority
strategic Porto Rosetta mama beyond Co
Co plays la France Nagi passel new o7o
tomorrow's agenda la mission de
formation UTM male encyclopedic Rosetta
mom Swanton tells for son la misma de
Luna says a present a son shell medal
foot a little one renew open all measure
as we don't look at the La Paz global
chaos en kill Vidan un grande valley a
suit a language model foxes are made
wasa company green strategy on Machado
governance Don vest is mo IDO
development economy jeongyeon okema
question keelhaul linear open Don tell
us your a
como hotel array of average a log
politic
don't pay dues I'll show mercy see
Monsieur next on the European Parliament
okay final one visits a Spanish
colleague and you so I'm always so open
to the left so miss Villanueva applause
yours thank you very much mr. president
bienvenido cinnamon deterministic
emission confit ahmo's ka muchas mess
veces
tres puntos muy rápido que vamos Tarija
comment ro you know a versa pay podía
and are en el significado de
l'indépendance i oh no Meah strategical
on europaea juste encontrada
des des des komete millas documentos
declaración este son Teddy or soos
asuras Niram of edenia on de la
independencia oh no Meah strategic ax y
la ACCA multi n a multilateral is mo y
me gustaría saber como piensa Ybarra
acabou secon are Sione's propias Canali
asses flexibles en un multi realities mo
kamo visto roto poured on alt ROM con le
a Logan necesita rusia escena promo ver
la paz implement ando la posición como
sobre
Irma's promo viendo leizerman super and
olaf a sexual dependency ax auntie
auntie una oten en segundo lugar bueno
never decay apprec amaz el comentario
respect America latina cake impart emos
cream o's case importante que Europa no
me Rath Yatra lado en un momento que
estamos viviendo la democracia hobo en
el continent a Kangol pays de estado
donde cream owes que Europa d-day bueno
pues Condon are estos golpes promo ver
media Sione's CeBIT are Auto proclaim a
CEO nays avatar la repression de la
protesta case está dando en America
latina usted habla de Lacey own SEO no
Micah's Masada's no Hetty Odessa Roy yo
nuestra scream OHS que también tiene que
estar Posadas n derechos labor a Lay's
media may entail AZN deSario Muto
siempre mi Rondo acabar con los Paso's
fiscales yo Ultimo a sobre la relación
de usted coma Alto representante yes
tape alimentar low pay o yo hablo en su
compare sin see a yo tambien a key
queremos que es importante que se pone
en este parlamento europeo institución a
blow pico mayor legitimate Democratic
apéro tenor una política Internacional
tan importante en estos momentos hace
que nos gustaría por tener compromiso
sell respect o Y poder compartir con
usted différentes Misiones pues
multiples vs. muchas gracias gracias
they say I do I ponder on from say that
Castillo on a surely say hello maybe I'm
on free pass I see canto violet don't do
the Sangji pay this I'll come voila
Kelly frontier on this one kid a lineal
back after making existed back me see
you later huh you don't walk a little
[ __ ] a hot face every demo [ __ ] down
off party I lost sheep I don't know get
a situation this Emily off ba hick malli
you bleep is he don't leave my leave and
now yeah and now say I'm either do told
about him I hope and get the about a
year on a nice good day we agree
Oh le président a burkina faso nudists
oohs no no sir Moya on a pad kebab the
cubrir Sudeten de la favas a Lara
billion euro zone persevere Cyril to
secrecy alley rabbit a lake on Flickr to
me on television with agriculture beyond
debate is decorative latter low-key monk
the climate report lays on day off past
recession as fake as air on violet air a
hablar Ron trade on TV and the rostrum
Olivier no Sheila from net a pint of
vanilla Cal kaizen a remedy McChrystal
pre-comp a rapist exact mo CDC pass a
new Hawk avec - Salaam a Franciscan on
PC francais bien Rizzo
Adam and Eve showed me a hope a key
party sip in touch kenapa energy -
colonial profoundly we the Francey
Josiah it's a hidden sin color
differences of cultural historic
Mexico's past Ava's
return zookeeper phenomena says an arena
vow of a career it escorial de la france
la Frontera hobbs said Oh sweets AHA
embodies critical mania
repair open perf participated envision a
cote de la France India destroyed our mo
satin no Janie foam pad omission dicamba
idea desi I am Britannic espanol massive
Ramon on the surface and the problem
kiss desire before the multiplier
beaucoup the deployment disarm a la
France to serve the paper FA s Konoha
anonymity
poor Declan Shane intervention
peacekeeping mission European Mara
homogeneous postponed
Caetano Hara har-ee limit a durable
mission hoping the profession coalition
of the will open Monday OPEC soon to say
engage a patent air poor kill a polar
reference a transaction commit a molar
solution lani Pattinson primo military
for patio de Distrito de tucumán
voulez-vous battle street or data toss
MP MP or a la madre security a person
donor hot white ricotta diff'rence
despair come pure mobile is a busy for
supplement a rain Barbarella normandy
Reforma Normandy with it laurent de
Paula noona hope and a panel survey to
survey a beaucoup de Sandra nappa may
Cosmo Mon Cala France Adele manual
pleases des initiative general discreet
avec minestrone OS at Tokyo ya quelques
Jaco dominance ian condition des
ministres ahead ranger español de se
passe bhadori
say patches case avid own a message via
neva donde mon pon de que arreglar see
info a la fois the near la política some
kill Tonkin muhabba you deserve a safe a
por esto y Napa may amend town a faux
pas refusal existence and Grampy keno
for needing energy available before
about the hopper compared to the p0p
Rizzoli youthful affair the maniera
organized a la mejor manera de faire say
they donate
crane GDD usually I bet to lop we don't
Allah as well the new president of
Ukraine refugee the Haiku Halle Fox our
maple have you paraded on bass set em on
pointed a path the refugee a fox army
prepare a may fall a fairly not facile I
said face on a pet daughter community
days Hotel Papa allow Russia s cassette
unit s will ever only call his
initiative price Paula Franz no gel Papa
Japan before to Sarah Leah busque a
commander espanol lo Cortez
Nikita lo Valiente at Kohanim a spa that
got wa la for Olivia lock until the fall
to tangle on the furmity kana they take
a puppet agave juice coming on me my
colleague and spaniel Allah you know you
know Eva no se que pull when Yadira
looking I reach over America latina and
he will be mizuna grab a Chrissy
sociology social no se que capacity any
Deegan esta meant a la unión europea la
union european como él para intervene en
esta Chrissy sociale que nos exploted o
las manos de una forma improv ISTA
tendremos que border los problemas
Mesirow gente y mi opinion msu gente es
venezuela non-date éramos que ser más
por act Evo's you enter co de la
población marae Solana esta su Ballymun
tada eso es consecuencia de las
políticas de san Sione's que effect on a
población you can europaea
no appliquéd Oh pero con los Estados
Unidos e yes or gente sorry unum pass
una situación donde los que paganella
Pato son los ciudadanos la seguro que
NSO voy a intentar hacer todo lo posible
por supuesto defender el multilateral is
no no no lo voy a repeater mass bestest
organ pisa paris area rhetoric oh no
pero SI sin duda porque alternatiba
multilateralism oh no es el
unilateralism Oh the alternative to
multilateralism is just the rule of the
stronger the leader must worthy that's
to say just the contrary of what do we
want we don't want the rule of the
stronger you want the rule of law and
that requires a multilateral approach to
the problems of the world and especially
in Latin America where as you were
saying and you said well there is a
social crisis which democracy has been
unable to prevent and all the democracy
will solve and now I am really sorry it
will be very happy to continue talking
with you but they are waiting for me in
Bratislava and I'm afraid they will have
to leave mr. Birrell we understand that
you have to leave to Bratislava your
office promised us 10 minutes more the
office promised us 10 minutes more I am
at door this or my office I will restate
them minis more great well thank you
even my office said that they should be
right ok
then without further ado the next is mr.
cole's from Latvia Thank You mr. chair
well have very straightforward question
so EU stands in a global world also as
the main advocate for democracy human
rights international law and etc and in
this regard I would love to hear the
hi representatives view on the adopting
--use wide Magnitsky act what is your
position do you see it feasible as
widening the the tools instruments that
is applicable to 21st century when we
are addressing outrage when it comes to
human right violations open ones and we
can implement these instruments I'm not
talking only by the the sanctions that
we have imposed on Russia where's you
know international law violations but
also on human rights because hi
representatives position is one way or
another also very much involved in
forming the sanctions and identifying
the the violators so I would love to
hear what is your position on the idea
of adopting the EU why the Magnitsky act
and the second one it's more as an
invitation for you to break the negative
practice that was formed by the your
predecessor and to join the CPSP meeting
in Croatia this march from 2nd of March
to 4th of March do in person that is
very valuable when it comes to
interacting with national parliaments
parliamentarians and exchanging views
that will be very much appreciated if
you would break this negative practice
that has been adopted so far thank you
thank you dear colleague next from the
European Parliament
Fabio Costello Thank You chair st model
to represent aunty credo use epistemic
content to consume number I mean to
super essentially so seguro que trabaja
ramos juntos en este mundo y ahora en
permit Amida continue our mi lenguin
italiano see stay una posición a commune
m selects for the army del concealed
emilio toma sembra Kuralt representante
que por troppo insisted efficacy study
memory known as Patino akritirian uno
demo TV / questa mankato respeto a
parable
La Senza DOMA Christmas and signatory Oh
nee confront Davila status on Enid MP n
Larry tiene que CA necesario DVD request
opposition a journalist yeah Lelouch
technology emergent Camille intelligence
artificial cyber technologies they are
military autonomy C alpha D state leader
regime addition Sione Athiya meant a
Robertson adidas receive and a
confronted equally study can you say
tengo la posición ecomony epidural team
o un servants Ernest very fleshy own
oscillatory Jie bian qu sono stato capo
servidor ad ration take a study Vanunu
difficile apparent ec deformation
executive o / remarkable honest
represents Ellen Ostra in periods
journal internal machine Adam original a
partnership reckon you know Depot key
partner current al punto de vista
democrático nel vision otto suit Graz
thank you next is manner fun Halford
from the Netherlands can you wave please
show you very much I'd like to
thank you very much mr. chair I'd like
to discuss China because today in the
Dutch newspapers that was said that in a
hospital of Rotterdam there was a
Chinese researcher working for Rotterdam
and taking and Beijing whose work is to
be used by the Chinese government to
track down dissidents and to track down
Igor's if this is true it's an evidence
of the way China thinks about human
rights and but also about the integrity
of nations and also how they think about
reciprocity in a bilateral relation and
if we talk about with Chinese China or
the Chinese ambassador about human
rights it's always said we think a
little bit different about human rights
and that can be but also they signed the
Universal Declaration of Human Rights I
think and that's why we can address each
other on that thing the United States
over things sanctions on China about
human rights about treating the igor's
but I also want to mention the organ
harvest and I want to ask you what
Europe will do and what you will do
about it okay thank you
mr. Birrell China Tunisia whatever you
wish
sanctions is also something very
difficult to manage we have to take care
with taking sanctions
I put example of Venezuela for example
sanctions that affect collectively a
people it's not sure that they can bring
back the result we are looking for and
by the country produced a lot of human
pain sanctions against individuals
that's what we are doing in the European
Union and we have been implementing
putting a lot of sanctions you are
asking about the possibility of
sanctioning the responsibles of attacks
to human rights in Russia and China I
have to deal with concrete cases they
cannot give general answer
Human Rights respect this part and
parcel of our talks with China very much
engage on that and you can believe that
eun-chae knees have a different approach
but as you said they have signed the
Convention of Human Rights and is part
of our talks and our discussions and our
agreements and disagreements but by the
time being it is not in the table of the
Council any proposal for sanctions on
the way you ask you for I am not very
much sure I know what is about this act
who has been mentioned menisci add no I
think is a someone who was killed
not sorry I don't know exactly what can
you explain me more and I don't know the
one who put the question that can repeat
the question please
mr. Colts you asked a question on the
Magnitsky Act would you like to repeat
your question well yes well when it's
key Act its so-called Magnitsky Act but
it's in different countries adopted as a
instrument a tool to track down the
human rights violators and call them
accountable in in a way of you know
freezing acids and other measures and
that is being adopted so far if I'm not
mistaking partially in six countries US
Canada and there are several EU Member
States but there is an idea to establish
the similar instrument at the EU level
and the question is do you support such
an initiative since the High
Representative is very much monitoring
globally what is happening in area on
human rights and human right violations
thank you and not answer this question
they don't have enough information about
it you say hi are you supporting this
idea and proposing to the council that
all European countries adopt this act
that as far as we know only six European
countries has taken this decision I
don't know we have to study it in order
to take it to give an answer colleague
called this the Foreign Affairs
Committee this morning adopted the draft
of the annual report on our common
foreign and security policy in the
European Union and we have mentioned a
referral to Magnitsky Act also being
introduced in the EU but it's a long way
to go but the issue is already being
discussed in our foreign affairs
committee that's for sure the other
questions China
okay good did you mr. Quesada Tunisia
that unity settle with the printer Abba
SL SL peak Co Vecchio printed in a
packet on bed on the regime dictatorial
Allah that you release it and grant a
spa for a democracy oh not that laughing
do you know in Tuscon approval over they
a Calif a democratic mess a tempeh on to
dizzy shaky vocalist agency Bay Massey
response capacity premier display la
democracy and Africa dinner and
contributing office on Tuscany Pavan PO
maintenance at a spa procurement a new
eco resort the situation derive a set a
clock Democratic separately on the
balloons a camel eras mountaintop in
aceite de la way contain she repeated in
European democracy until you see
okay Thank You mr. Birrell your first
appearance in the European Parliament at
our annual meeting with representatives
of the national parliaments thanks for
presenting yourself and your first views
in your in policy thanks for answering
the questions a final remark from your
side yes they haven't answered it about
the question if I am going to go to
Croatia well I will be delighted to go
to Croatia so you already take this
commitment and I will be there looking
forward to seeing you again in Zagreb
live and in color that's an important
statement you made at the end and I
think that's a good message also for all
creation hosts colleagues Commissioner
vihari is on his way he will be here in
three minutes may I please ask you to
focus mainly on enlargement and
neighborhood issues because these are
the dossiers mr. very is working on
thank you